first for you t I always love hearing
about how a film evolves along the way
so what would you say is the biggest
difference between draft one of this
screenplay and what everyone will now
see in the finished film oh I don't even
remember draft draft one um it's pretty
much the same story uh you know most of
the beats are the same um I think we
probably just ended up on this
particular film I think a lot of the
time we sort of we did versions of
script and then went off script a lot
and a lot of things developed and
evolved throughout the shoot as us
usually um as it usually does on my
films um like for instance there's a
character Armani this kid that hangs out
this you doesn't say anything he hangs
out with um with G and with
Thomas and Michael just came up to me
one day said I've been talking to this
cool kid who's just been hanging out on
the you know near the set you should put
him in the movie and I said okay and he
the next day so there was like a week or
two into shooting and then we put them
in and um I was felt like going into
this to really just accept and open up
to like any idea or any sort of
development that could happen and not be
too strict and because a lot of the film
thematically it's about just letting go
not trying to control too many things
and just sort of going with the flow oh
this kind of Builds on this G Ty no I
like big old complicated compound
question so a two-parter for you now so
Jes when you first heard
that the documentary was going to be
turned into a scripted feature what was
a top priority for you in terms of an
element of your true experience that you
really wanted to see represented in this
film but then on the other hand to lean
into what Tao was just saying what is
something about the finished film that
kind of like caught you by surprise
something you didn't think it would
capture but really appreciated I think
um I'm most grateful that Tao was the
one who took on this project because
he's a Pacific Islander and he knows the
sensitivities that are that surround the
Fafa identity so that was my biggest
concern um when I first heard that um
Tao was going to do this this project
um a surprise um I think the biggest
surprise for me was the fact that he was
generous enough to give me a lead role
in the movie or kaimana um yeah I was
just one story of many different stories
in the documentary um but in this film
um I felt pretty special um I mean he
was generous enough to even give me
goals when I didn't score any goals but
so oh a God I can do what I want in my
world when I create a world in a film I
am the Creator yeah so there were a
couple of pleasant
surprises look if you want the real real
authentic Story Watch the documentary
exactly and I mean documentries aren't
even that real are they they're just
little moments edited together to create
a certain point of view and a certain
narrative based on what the filmmaker
wants you to think or feel if you really
want the true true true true story get a
time machine and go back there yeah oh
yeah that's experience on the day even
the timeline in the dog was just yeah
the timeline yeah back and forth yeah
yeah I need to highlight Kima ta I'll
throw the first question um on that
topic to you because like what what did
you see in her that signal to you like
yes you can handle a lead role in this
pretty big feature film for your acting
debut well there are few few boxes to to
take when you're trying to cast for this
particular role um you know we want
authenticity for you know so like we I
needed someone who A was Simon b i
identified as trans to see who um could
play soccer already those are three very
hard things to to combin get right and
with four the most important thing is
that they could act and so like when you
when yeah there were a few people who
came in and K Mana ticked all of those
boxes and um I felt like you know I
instantly felt like she was able to do
the job and and then she did her first
scenes with Michael and he was like whoa
she good really like and so it was um
you I just felt that was a huge relief
to be able to you know because that was
a very important role to cast obviously
I'm dying to see her in more things now
uh G for you did you get the chance to
chat with K kaima before filming and if
so what were some you know elements of
the movie version that were most
important for the two of you to talk
through and maybe even work on together
um again this was so kaim is playing
ta's version of GA so um the first time
we met was at the launch party for the
film I was actually a guest of one of
the cast members and I walked in not
knowing anybody but um Kim stood out uh
we got to chat a little um not as um
colleagues pertaining to the film but
more so as um you know introductory um
meet and just getting a feel of who each
other um is and um now we're good
friends I think that was important yeah
so one of my favorite ideas that this
movie puts forth is like no pressure
enjoy yourselves it's just a game so ta
I want to turn that idea towards film
making which is like an unden able high
pressure business and also art so
whether it's next goal wins or any other
film you've made can you recall a Time
on set when you had to remind yourself
of the excitement of making a movie and
because of that it helped you overcome a
very challenging moment in a production
I think every time I drive to work um
the closer I get to set the more excited
I get and I always that's what reminds
me is the idea that you know that no one
has really figured out this isn't a real
job and we get to like just you know put
different clothes on and masks on and
pretend to be people all day and um you
know and it's the one of it's the best
job I can think of and I still get that
real kind of just that buzz of going to
work and going I can't believe I get to
do this um I try not to stress I've
always tried not to stress CU it's the
silent killer and uh and but on set it's
very hard not to you the pressure is
very great I think usually it's
um I I I'm very I'm able to sort of um
to I just know that if it is a high
stress situation you know you're not
sure what the outcome's going to be um
that's actually a good place to be in
because if you know that your next move
the entire time it's kind of boring and
it's uh doesn't seem much point to me so
I like those moments when it's like what
the hell is going to happen and um and
then when you get out of it that you
know when you manage to pull something
off or um figure out a solution to a
problem um you feel you feel very smart
sure I had an ad buddy who used to walk
around sets when people were stressed
and say guys we're making a movie and
now every single time I'm having a tough
moment I always think I can hear him
still to this day saying it and I love
it thank you Perry You're So luy to be
to make a movie it's so you know so rare
now